go to Texas Republican Tony Gonzalez has
a unique distinction of representing a
district that includes better than 800
miles on the border Congressman very
good to have
you thank you Neil for having me this
back and forth and the lawsuits now
expanding from the white house uh to go
after the the governor's plan to have uh
law enforcement arrest migrants uh have
judges Deport them that goes too far
secondly saying this action to ship
migrants to All Points North uh also an
illegal act so a lot of suing going on
here but not a lot to doing going on
here yeah the doj should focus on
protecting Americans and not suing
Texans uh but before getting further
into the Border I represent y valdi so
seeing what happened in Iowa the school
shooting in Iowa is very real uh I
reached out to Zach nun who represents
Perry Iowa and our teams are working
together when there was a a shooting in
Maine I reached out to to Jared golden
who's a Democrat and working on this and
you know these shootings imagine I mean
you imagine you're eating breakfast at
at school that all of us have done and
you get murdered uh I mean this has to
come to an end and i' I've been an
advocate we can both protect our
children in school and we can also
protect the Constitution this whole it
has to be either or is nonsense but I I
wanted to mention that because it's just
it's a very raw emotion that I'm feeling
well and and justifiably so we don't
know all the details but to your point
Congressman the two sides agreeed that
it's got to stop but sadly it doesn't
and and related to this border issue the
two sides agree we've got to do
something about this outright Civ that
has allowed tens of thousands tender
this country and a pace it's picking up
but how do you do that right now the
best that you know a few dozen of your
colleagues could do yesterday in a visit
to the Border was to point out that the
president isn't isn't doing anything and
that the the homeland security secretary
should resign or be
impeached how how does that move theall
for
yeah I mean a big part of life is
showing up and the fact that we've got
we got over 60 members to show up
yesterday and all of a sudden the spet
got turned off and all of a sudden
yesterday this whole week actually
there's been over a thousand border
patrol Agents from the Del Rio sector
that were not processing people that
were out in the field doing their job
that is a win that is what they should
be doing two weeks ago when I was in
Eagle Pass where there were thousands of
people in in detention they were zero
border patrol agents out there tomorrow
I will be hosting my 22nd Congressional
codell this time will be a Democrat
it'll be Don Davis from North Carolina
so I think this is a positive uh
development where we're going to have
you know I think this can't be a
partisan issue this has to be in a in a
bipartisan manner how do we secure our
border and keep America all Americans
safe now you stood out not too long ago
Congressman for for kind of bristling at
your party that some of its measures
were a little severe um you you've since
said that the the the overall goal of
trying to cut down on this incredible
migrant surge was your your only goal uh
but but it it it did make me get back to
this mayorca situation the move to
impeach him because that might or might
not happen but it's unlikely without the
president letting it happen without the
president just saying you got to go
you're a disaster that doesn't appear
likely so is that move a waste of
time I think American demand uh we hold
people accountable uh but going down the
impeachment route I mean you can already
see what's going to happen let's say the
house is successful in peaches my in
peaches my orcus and we all you know uh
Pat ourselves on the back as fast as we
possibly can how does that help us
secure the Border uh I'm I'm looking at
real tangible Solutions and part of that
is finding a way I work very hard on on
House Bill hr2 I work with my colleagues
we arm wrestled we put we put together a
bill that could ultimately get in the
house I was speaking earlier today with
uh one of my one of the Senators that is
in negotiating this package I want them
to be successful and ultimately I want
to see a a National Security package
that isn't window dressing that actually
addresses some of the solutions what
I've been advocating for House
Republicans should be advoc should be
fighting for a down payment on border
security in 2024 and we come back for
the rest when we win the White House got
it we'll watch it closely Congress and
thank you for taking the time to speak
with us it's been a busy few days for
you that's an understatement hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else